how are you supposed to find a good girl
if you're not telling them like that
you're a nerd up front yeah that's
basically the question because i get
bored with the good girls yeah but if
you're oh my god
okay what's wrong with a good girl
what the [ __ ] is going on
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of the
unwax podcast with your hoedown throat
on sister sistine and her hype man
sophia you guys
i'm a little flustered right now
why are you flustered we just wrapped an
interview with uh
a boy that is
too hot to handle i did say that in the
intro so he is too hot to handle and um
it was honestly i'll be honest he was a
lot
cuter in person than i thought you guys
the vibes sophia was throwing at him
that's not true
sophia this is what i knew sophia was
done
in the interview you guys will you guys
will hear in a second
he said
i can pull a girl in with my eyes and
sophia's move
is pulling a guy in with her eyes so the
eyes were so strong meanwhile i was
literally just twiddling my thumbs
uh you know i'm just a natural born
flirt i just oh god well it's a really
fun interview you guys will hear it but
we're gonna give you uh
a weekly update right now i just got
back from vegas yesterday
feva las vegas was there anything that
you had to leave in vegas
my money
that's true no no i went i went gambling
um and i was so excited for it because i
genuinely thought beginner's luck i
can't lose i'm gonna do so well i was so
bad and i'll tell you what killed me
what the freaking slots yeah wait i have
to say when she said she went to slots i
uh that was your first red flag and dumb
move you never win it
so rigged
i was playing with my boyfriend we
pulled the lever and we went 120 and i
was like oh my god we're winning we're
up
i lost it all within three polls
um i told you to do roulette she text me
i did do roulette yeah and i said i gave
you numbers i gave you colors and guess
what your numbers gave me squat oh
squat oh i'm sorry i know usually i i
maybe that first time i did it that was
a lucky streak so you lost all your
money yeah um did you do anything else
in vegas we ate a lot of good food cause
she was there for the adele concert that
postponed yes so her and her boyfriend
were like we're just gonna with the
family his family which is here actually
yes was that were you nervous to go with
the family to no i wasn't nervous
because we've gotten a few dinners at
this point but they're just so nice it
was just a really lovely easy weekend i
couldn't even imagine
the difference if if our family were to
do that vegas trip it would just be
absolute chaos it was kind of nice just
being so relaxed with
chill people yeah yeah we went golfing
and that's the only thing that was
really nice she was really nervous about
me because i was trying to of course
you know talk myself up in the beginning
of the relationship and i was like yeah
i golf i'm a great golfer i'm so good
and
eventually before the trip the parents
come up to me and they go all right
let's see how good you really are and i
was like gulp oh yeah if you're bad
that's gonna be really embarrassing
i
didn't do that bad yeah i will admit my
drive was not great
but my woods were good
would work honestly there's nothing more
embarrassing than when you say you are
so good at something like you're bowling
i'm so gonna kick your ass and then all
of a sudden you get there and it's
gutter it was the entire time exactly
yeah so thank god thank you because it
really with our golf game we are good
and i'm absolutely inconsistent but very
inconsistent because we don't do it
enough so some days we're on fire it's
almost hole-in-ones and then some days
it is but my lesson is learned i'm never
gonna hype myself up again it's better
to act like you're really bad at
something and then exceed their
expectations but i'm gonna take her back
to vegas and give her a true
true vegas trip what's your version of
true vegas
the classic
morning clubs or morning clubs day clubs
night clubs going to steakhouses
gambling and actually winning something
like things like that like that's true
you know like what happens in vegas
stays in vegas and i want to give you
that almost borderline hangover movie
but not to the point where we lose
something you know i actually did watch
that movie and no drugs on this trip i
was like okay i gotta watch the hangover
no that's like the worst
his family especially like okay gotta
recreate this i'm getting a face tattoo
and getting a monkey i would die i know
what did you do while i was gone it was
actually kind of weird right when i left
you you were like i miss you yeah i
missed you
yeah well i hung out with gabby hi gabby
and um gaby looked disappointed by that
god thanks guys we shared a bottle of
wine and we just talked we literally
talked for like four hours honestly i
have to say literally this weekend i did
nothing and when i say nothing i mean
how amazing is it when you have a
weekend and you don't have anything
planned and you actually can just calm
down that's my favorite thing to do
right because there's every week and
yeah i look forward to the weekend after
working all week but there's nothing
better when you actually have nothing
planned and you can sleep in you wake up
not hungover you get to work out it's
just detoxing waking up not except with
her
no you we need to have those friends but
waking up not hungover is probably one
of my favorite things to do now we act
like we wake up hanging over
like it used to be when when you just
turned 21 it's like all you want to do
is be 21 and go out every weekend it's
so nice
saturday and sunday think about it let
me tell you nothing feels better yeah
like drinking a few tequila sodas yeah
you feel good but nothing beats waking
up at 8am on a saturday no hangover
feeling great even even like not
drinking one thing like cause sometimes
even having like tiny bit of alcohol my
sleep is kind of off in some way i just
have a headache in the morning because
your body is just not as good as you
feel like i know in college i could
drink and it would just
not wake up and go to my 8 a.m but now
it you just feel one glass of wine and
so well i just realized just do that how
pathetic we sound like genuinely sophia
what the hell are we what the hell what
the hell are we actually talking about
what is what i kind of like it no okay
no we gotta no that's not good i'm gonna
snap us out of that we just said that we
hate being social and going out and
having fun because we would rather wake
up early on on sunday
what is wrong with that but guess what
what are we doing
but guess what guess what
we don't have to worry about that this
weekend because this weekend is super
bowl
go round oh really she's going to the
super bowl i am going to the super bowl
i am very excited i will be studying
football yeah a lot i can teach you if
you need me too i'm actually excited
just to eat hot dogs
what was it lizzie's glitzy
nose all right we're so excited this
weekend's gonna be really fun we have an
event on friday we're doing some fun
things on saturday then super bowl
sunday we're not doing fun things we're
doing not a double date a triple date
whoa wow
singer i actually i was gonna bring this
up because i know a lot of people were
asking in the comments actually which i
was very surprised about because i
didn't think people probably really
cared but i got so many comments saying
what happened on your double date i love
that the listeners are keeping yeah they
working throughout the week because i
was like you know i can just like
slide by that i don't need to mention
yeah it went really well okay are you
talking about your one-on-one date or
your double date
oh
so yeah did i ever mention that i got
one you did but you never followed up oh
so both dates went really really well
and we did talk about the double date
but i do want to actually ask you
questions about your one-on-one okay
sure because you came back and said it
was one of the best dates you've ever
had and i feel like what he did wasn't
so
out of the ordinary that
that nobody could actually do themselves
it was really simplistic yet perfect and
i feel like you should give the people
some insight on what made it so good
are you talking about the beach one yes
okay so why i thought this was such a
perfect date and it wasn't yeah he was
great company and obviously we get along
really well and i think that when you go
out with someone the one thing that i've
realized even i've been i always say
like single for a really long time and
i've gone on a lot of dates and what
made this a little different was the
fact that you didn't feel like you had
to try so hard and we always say that
like when you and i realized that i
forgot about that because i feel like
every time i go on dates i'm trying
really hard to be funny but aside aside
from the emotions but i'm just saying
that that was the initial thing of why
it was fun but the date part of it like
my question is did he pick you up yeah
so check
yeah so the thing is look i know people
always in the comments oh like
preference like he doesn't have to i get
it for me i appreciate it so he picked
me up we went to the beach we cooked
dinner together it was just really no
but he did things like you guys drink a
bottle of wine at the beach and watch
the sunset like that's
a bottle of wine is
14 bucks the sun sets free
it'll make a girl very happy but that's
the thing is like i didn't need it to be
the most extravagant thing ever
you need didn't need to do like a
hundred okay we gotta go get drinks
dinner this this you don't need to spend
all this money yeah honestly what made
it was nice was because it was so easy
it wasn't something over complicated we
were pretty much in one place the whole
time and we got to really know each
other by doing things like walking on
the beach or cooking together or just
sitting watching the sunset talking like
it was really
intimate but also really good to get to
know the person that you're sitting
across from well i'm happy yeah it was a
good life
yeah it was i liked him it was cool
i don't know i can tell you i could tell
you are trying so hard to be like yeah
yeah it's cool it's good it's cool i
just yeah
yeah i just don't know it just
she's like let's pivot um should we talk
about who we have on the show today yes
please
you couldn't have said that faster
so you guys yes we have stevon ditter
from too hot to handle season three he
was the la bad boy dream boy that every
girl wants to have but hates to lose you
guys you've got to watch the show on
netflix it is such an easy binge they
bring all these people together in a
house thinking that they're on some
crazy party sex fun show
come to realize that they're not allowed
to even
kiss someone touch someone and it's all
about building your emotional intimacy
when i saw him on the show he was my
favorite he was yes is he cute obviously
but he was just really outspoken and
just didn't care in the beginning and it
was so fun to watch him and then why he
ended up still being my favorite is
he'll talk about his transition it's you
can totally tell the difference between
how he started and how he ended and yeah
episode is really funny it's really
spicy really chaotic definitely spicy
viewer discretion advised if you love
strippers we're talking a lot about no
we are truly diving into this boy's
brain
and probably how most men think so stay
tuned for that
i
feel so happy right now
i'm surprised why because it's my
favorite part of the episode sophia and
why is that sistine because we get to do
the best ad read ever for my favorite
brand
mr manscaped himself
sexiest one of them all mr manscaped we
are excited to announce today that
manscape's brand new ultra premium
collection believe it or not they're
moving above the bikini line folks what
so we're talking about upgrading the man
in your life's hygiene routine with your
favorite manly scent this all-in-one
skin and hair kit is for the everyday
man that covers him from head to toe
quite literally you guys a self-care
routine is so important so we all know
what a game changer manscaped the
lawnmower 4.0 has been for trimming
below the waist i love the lawnmower
what a genius name by the way oh they
have really good names for their
products so and now you guys can enhance
his perfect grooming routine with her
ultra premium collection this package
includes manscape's premium deodorant
not only for his balls but say goodbye
to his smelly armpit hugs there's also
the hydrating body sway which is great
for tattoos and people with dry skin so
it's designed to keep the skin feeling
smooth moisturized and smelling fresh
in addition there's also shower
essentials included like their body wash
and their two-in-one shampoo and
conditioner plus
free gift who doesn't like free gifts me
i love free gifts
so you guys can get a three pack of set
of lip balm to keep those lips feeling
moist a lip balm is so good you're
guaranteed to steal one or two from his
set that's four products plus a gift
inside the ultra premium collection all
of these products are cruelty free
paraben free vegan friendly and dye free
it is the best ingredients with zero
compromise if this doesn't sound good
enough you guys can get 20 off and free
shipping with the code unwaxed at
manscaped.com again that's 20 off plus
free shipping with the code unwaxed
manscape.com the only smell you'll want
on him
in a bottle thanks to manscaped
you guys our next partner is green chef
it is a ccof certified meal kit company
green chef makes eating well easy with
plans to fit every lifestyle whether
you're keto paleo vegan vegetarian
gluten free or just looking to eat more
balanced meals green chef offers a range
of recipes to suit your preferences
green chef is the most sustainable meal
kit enjoy your greens while also being
green green chef offsets 100 of their
plastic packaging in every box and 100
of their carbon footprint and emissions
as we mentioned they're convenient and
easy so you can spend less time
stressing and more time enjoying
delicious home-cooked meals green chefs
pre-made and pre-measured sauces
dressings and spices to get more of your
chef curated flavor in less time that
makes it so easy green chef offers 35
nutritious and flavorful options to
choose from every week featuring premium
clean ingredients that are seasonally
sourced for peak freshness
green chef's always changing variety of
easy to follow recipes means there's
something new to discover each week so
you're never going to get bored look
sometimes sophie and i get super busy
especially on days where we shoot so
it's really exciting for us to use green
chef to take care of meal planning
grocery shopping and meal prep it's nice
for them to take care of that even on
days we don't shoot so if you guys want
in on this awesome deal go to
greenchef.com
unwaxed130 and use code unwaxed130
to get a hundred and thirty dollars off
plus free shipping say to the people in
the back again that is green chef dot
com slash unwax 130 and use the code on
wax 130 to get 130 off plus free
shipping try the number one meal kit for
eating well
not to sound cliche but this guy is too
hot to handle oh okay
not only is this handsome la guy a model
and a dj but he was also on netflix
series um season three of too hot to
handle and most recently captioned his
photo life is short mike is not wow go
get his tattoo this is seven dinners
i actually when i went on your page and
i saw that i was like i don't know why
but that was the funniest commission and
it's so simple you're a poet too yeah
yeah i do haikus you know you can hire
me i'll figure it out perfect you pegged
me as the type of guy i think you were
cringing while she was hyping you up oh
absolutely
i i like to come across as the nicest
[ __ ] you ever meet so like i act like
a prick to the general public
but then when you get to know me i'm not
so like as soon as you say like my
pricky things that i do and the stupid
[ __ ] that i do i i i cringe at myself
yeah i totally get that i think you
cringed and i was like hyping you up
this morning i don't like i don't like i
love giving people attention and
compliments but i hate them myself i
hate it but someone told me one time
when they were paying me a bunch of
compliments i was like no i'm ugly and i
actually smell really bad i haven't
showered in days and he's like how about
you just say thank you i was like you're
right i should probably say thank you so
life is short mine is not
where was the inspiration behind this
did you get any what were any responses
you received um i i got a lot of good
responses
um yeah you know a lot of it was i don't
know if you remember when ariana grande
and pete davidson dated yeah after they
broke up she told everybody that it was
huge
yeah and he went around saying like you
know i honestly hate it because now
everybody's underwhelmed when they see
it and taken aback by it well i don't
know because now he's dating kim k so he
must that's what i'm saying i took one
out of the books he seemed to do it
right and he's doing great now so i was
like all right let's hype myself up even
if i'm wrong at least someone's gonna
get a laugh
i want to actually talk about how your
dms and your life has changed after too
hot to handle so you're actually the
second person that we've had
from uh two out of ten
harley lawrence okay i love carly yeah
she's so sweet so i'm excited to have a
male's perspective on the show
and she was telling us a lot of
behind-the-scenes stuff that i actually
had no idea because i was like when do
you guys eat
did you have to quarantine for two weeks
there yeah you have to do all that as
well yeah so i had to quarantine for two
weeks um part of the reason why like by
the end of it i was kind of losing it on
the show just because there was no
communication to the outside world yeah
so after two weeks by yourself and i'm a
stoner so like no weed
nothing no no phone number you're bored
out of your mind losing it
and then you meet like a group of 10
people and everyone else just went
through that so you guys become such a
like close-knit group that every single
situation seems to be a little harder
hitting or more to the heart or whatever
the situation is because it seemed
really emotional when someone would make
a connection or relationship it just
seemed like zero to a hundred percent
right and things move
seven days at a time there in one day
just because you're only there for so
long so the connections happen like that
and then when people get kicked off or
whatever which i didn't know people got
kicked off yeah i didn't know
that either yeah so when it happened i i
just i lost it so that was definitely a
situation but the food was bombed i'll
give you that yeah we had i think it was
rihanna's five-star chef oh you guys had
chefs there oh in-house chef that's
right
it was like full buffet meals that they
would give you three times a day and you
just eat whatever you want so you
probably knew immediately when you saw
that
cone thing that it was the show that did
did you guys really know no i had no
idea let me let me just explain to you
the show comes up yeah it's like sex
island and you're like all right
but it kind of i feel like we should
give some context to what the show is
it's basically a bunch of horny adults
put on an island and they're tested to
see if they can make a real connection
without any sexual
fornication going on yeah we get [ __ ]
blocked by a cone that's usually okay
exactly so they tricked you guys to
joining because i don't think anyone in
the right mind would want to join that
correct especially the people that they
want on the show right they tricked you
yeah they they contacted me i'll be
honest when i first got contacted was
over instagram i got a dm and i was
dating a girl at the time and
i woke up the next morning both dms were
gone different people same same show or
whatever both were gone so i asked her i
was like did you go through my phone
last night and delete this and she's
like nah nah it wasn't me oh okay but
she was a compulsive liar so like
i finally got it out of her and she's
like yeah i did and i was like well now
i'm gonna go on it just because you told
me not to wait wait wait wait wait wait
so much to unpack yeah so obviously that
was that i ended it right there did you
done that before oh yeah she it was
about my question is why do you give
your phone password yeah why did you oh
she had her face in the thing it wasn't
even a phone like she got her full face
id in there how long were you guys
dating like a month that's it
does she track your location too oh yeah
oh no oh yeah where did you find this
one they're all over what are you
talking about
you guys have situations that aren't
like this because that's every
relationship i'm in i think you're just
choosing the same type of girl in just
like different varieties yeah oh my god
if i don't get their face in my phone
after a month i'd be like all right but
she's probably watching this season i'm
losing her mind for sure have you heard
from her at all no i'm blocked
maybe that's good i think i would block
her no i don't block people i like i
like a little bit of chaos you did yeah
but she fully blocked me but essentially
she did all that and so i was like
[ __ ] i'm gonna go on the show
and
then i
once i like they told me like okay
you're gonna come on this is what it is
blah blah i had no care in the world i
wasn't trying to read into it or figure
it out i was like all right whatever
let's do it and then i woke up one day
and there's a cone telling me i can't
have sex
see this whole process was really
fascinating to me and i'm not just
blowing smoke up your ass when i say
this but sophia goes you gotta watch the
season you gotta watch this guy it's
really hysterical you were
but it kind of made me sad because you
didn't find a connection at all
um you got pie you got tied i mean don't
get me wrong the way i looked at it was
that
i didn't want to come out of the show in
a relationship okay
i i again just got out of a really toxic
relationship as you guys both know now
uh headspace wasn't right so like i went
into it a little differently than i
would usually i'd just not really care
about emotions do whatever i wanted
seemed to be more like realistic towards
what's going on try and be friendly
towards the people and make a
relationship out of it and it just
didn't work but in my head every
relationship whether it was with a homie
or one of the friends after the fact or
whatever is still a relationship in
itself right so i'm still really close
with everybody on the show oh that's
good i'm a flirt with everybody on the
show i don't care so like i'm still
getting out of it what i want to get out
of it right and now i still get to do
whatever i want you're still hanging out
yeah exactly i didn't have to go wait
for the show to come out to hide a
relationship or something like that i
kept doing me kept vibing doing me this
moment and is there anything that the
show restricts you from doing or talking
about i mean to an extent yeah but a lot
of me like they put me on the show
because i break rules and i do whatever
i want right yeah right so like i'll i
try and follow what netflix tells me to
do and listen to them but i definitely
have like my own stay on it i i let
people know what i think i'm not afraid
to stand up for it and yeah i really
feel like i should be doing something i
do it anyway but
most of the time yeah they have some
things to say but they're pretty lenient
was there anyone on the show that you
were like surprised that you were
attracted to
nah i like everybody
you don't know
no i don't ha i mean my mom says i have
a type she's what she's blondes i love
blondes but
you know the first person i went for on
the show wasn't a blonde that's true i
mean i i really am about personality you
could be the most beautiful person out
there and if your personality is [ __ ] it
doesn't matter okay so what about a
woman's personality attracts you you got
to make me laugh like you have to be
able to just vibe if you take things too
seriously like
that's my job that's my job to be like
the anxious ones sometimes and like
protective but like if you're too
serious over it kind of just pushes me
away a little bit i just need someone to
let me do me and then i'll fall into
place properly you know i feel like
that's something that everyone looks for
whenever i ask someone that question
then we we always say like yeah a funny
guy but it's surprising how many unfunny
people there are no 100 people in your
life bland but no one here is funny i
think everyone in this industry is not
funny that's why i like new york and
like miami because it's a lot more like
straightforward nobody's being fake or
bullshitting each other it's just i'll
say what i want and i'll laugh at the
truth like i'd much rather laugh at the
truce and be taken aback by something
that's for sure and our parents moved to
florida and we were in miami so you guys
went through funny i know so we went to
it
right now it's crazy
and i feel like everyone's just up for
having a good time because here it's
just so different no everybody's stingy
i know are you from l.a no i'm from
baltimore oh really when did you come
out here i've been here four years now
and i did three in new york before that
oh so did you ever go back to new york
oh 100 so i would love to be here you're
also a model do you still model today is
that why you were living in new york
that's why i was in new york yeah i
dropped out of college and started
modeling in new york and then i did like
djing and nightlife i worked for cal
group put some like did marijuana [ __ ]
out there and everything and then moved
out here to like solidify all of it well
it was really funny because before we
started recording you actually triggered
me oh god you really triggered me you
said that we worked on a shoot together
oh yeah and i i told you
it was this shoot in particular that
actually gives me night sweats when i
think about it
it is
it was a vogue arabia prom themed photo
shoot oh my god and i remember just i
had like a beehive on the top of my head
i looked so ugly and i also remember
that everyone like you were hanging out
with people everyone was sort of talking
to everyone i hid in the basement i hid
in the basement because i had no friends
i think i was like 19 at the time i was
like really scared of everybody scared
of my shadow it's kind of my reflection
honestly the way they made me look but i
i mean i guess it's so crazy that like
small world i think that's so freaky
that you guys have known each other for
that long oh you went through no i took
it no no but now we're cool now we're
friends okay but i feel like are you
still more into modeling or do would you
want to get more into djing you know
modeling was only ever a thing for me
because i knew i could do it yeah like
where i'm from again baltimore city we
don't have an entertainment industry
right so i did all of it on my own i
made the agency i got signed and all
that my parents all thought it was fake
so i that's more like something i've
already conquered at this point i do it
i i make my money and my bills from it
it's handled properly and then now music
has always been my thing of what i
wanted to do yeah so this is where i'm
really stepping into that and like make
making sure that my bearings are down
and yeah i get structured deep house uh
deep house trap dubstep i'll do just
about anything um i love dubstep oh yeah
not a good dancer but i see my feet can
move quite fast but i'm not a good guy i
i highly doubt seeing either of you
oh let's run it but it you said i think
it's interesting you said that your
parents thought it was fake the careers
that you wanted to pursue what do your
parents do if you don't mind me asking
so my parents owned a restaurant for
about 25 years oh cool and now they just
like kovitz shut it down and all that
and at the time my mom had been starting
a furniture company so now they run that
together but they just run very like
mom and dad stuff of course that's why
i'm thinking like okay so you're trying
to pursue something completely out of
their world right and then i had a
brother with down syndrome too when i
was three so like all the family members
that said he should do baby modeling or
kid modeling or this and that a lot of
the attention had to go focus on him and
make sure that he was doing his classes
and understanding everything so i just
went independent on everything yeah and
so like i think it was like 17 years old
i got an american eagle campaign all on
my own wow paid 400 bucks like [ __ ]
you're like
no man
it's a big deal that you got in the
first one right but my parents thought i
was going sex trafficking like they were
they were for sure that i was going to
end up in saudi arabia or something like
that how were you as a kid where you
were you said you ended up in vogue i
was really good as a kid really i didn't
party till i was like 17 years old i
didn't drink what were you like in high
school you're a good student i'm a nerd
i was like
come on you're melting every girl's
heart
do you think oh yeah i'm a weird kid all
right all right let's get let's get
let's get deep how nerdy is nerd because
some people are like i like star wars
but then others are like i build legos
video games book nerd like that i think
more of a
socially awkward nerd where like i can
talk to people but i'm definitely a
little quirky and like i just have some
things like i wasn't i didn't have a lot
of friends in high school
welcome to our world
yeah like it just it wasn't for me um
but as i've come out of that and lived
in like a normal life i've tend to have
found people that are actually more
normal and right don't care about their
image and whatnot but like i mean i was
getting pretty good grades i played
sports and that was it i didn't do
anything else i didn't hang out with
people i didn't party i didn't yeah it's
funny because first impression you
wouldn't think that it'd be
what do you people give you like first
impressions i'm i'm an [ __ ] like
they're like oh you're a [ __ ] boy you
you don't care what anybody thinks this
and that and that's kind of the idea
that i portray to people yeah yeah um
only because i've had such negative
experiences in my life i've stopped
wanting that surface level experience
yeah so i give off an uh like
an idea that you wouldn't necessarily
want to be around and then once you get
to know me so you're wearing it sort of
as a shield to protect who you really
are to people because i don't want to
waste my time i agree especially in l.a
it's really hard to make a genuine
connection and i definitely find myself
uh acting a different way when i'm
around a different group of people i'm
like wait this isn't i don't even like
to do this stuff i don't know this isn't
me have you had it uh an easy time
making friends in the lights i know it's
hard i think i've had a really easy time
in la because i did new york first so
like we said earlier how i oh i'm just
very blunt and standoffish and i'll tell
you exactly how it is when i do that to
people that are from born and raised in
la they're not used to it so they almost
respect it a little bit yeah and it's
unanticipated so they
like that difference whereas they're
used to everybody just
talking they're doing whatever they want
to make them feel better about
themselves so it honestly did work out
for me in that essence um and it's kept
a lot of the fakes away so i have like a
really hard knit group of people now in
la that i stick true to that i help out
i scratch their back they scratch mine
we take care of yeah i was from since
the show came out how do you think your
life's changed from them because now you
have to probably be even more selective
kind of selected yeah like who you're i
think
i think a lot of it has to do with
whoever has been there in the past year
waiting for it to drop who's actually
been around and i've seen that who
hasn't looked for anything for me
because obviously i couldn't tell
anybody what i did right yeah so it was
more me just taking in how people
treated me and realizing that now they
are the expendable things here and not
me
um but honestly i haven't had a polar
change really more getting noticed in
public right like i went to vegas a
little while ago and every day some
random person on the casino table would
come up and stop me no i'd be like
you're a 43 year old man why are you
watching too often no
he's like you're my favorite casper yeah
literally and i'm like all right man
that's cool like thank you i appreciate
that but that's the only weird thing for
me because i am like a little bit uh
introverted so like the whole idea of
talking to somebody that knows me and i
don't know them is a little bit weird
how are you supposed to find a good girl
if you're not telling them like that
you're a nerd up front yeah that's
basically the goal because i get
what's wrong with a good girl yeah
what's wrong i'm a good girl we'll make
your cookies and rub your feet there's
nothing wrong with that i mean i get the
toxic ones to do that too but the
difference is that we won't put your
face our face in your phone okay well
then i get bored i want a little bit of
chaos
i want something to keep it going like a
little bit of like tug and pull yeah for
sure whole relationship no absolutely
yeah but i haven't i've gotten past that
yet
have you ever had like a serious
girlfriend for a long time the most
serious girlfriend i had was two years
and she was a stripper
you are full of surprises yeah then we
got speechless i honestly i'm like oh my
god he's the sweet introvert nerd that
dates strippers like this is crazy
that's it you hate it
wait so dania stripper how are you how
are you able to
do that because i know a lot of guys be
like i can't have my girlfriend stripped
for other men well
it definitely took a toll later on in
the relationship yeah
but i'm big on trust i i do like trust
like that's a big thing so
i'm good with you until the minute you
lie to me
as soon as you lie to me i'll never
trust you you've never cheated
good never say never
we didn't say that
no i will say the one the one time i
fully cheated
was i got cheated on first oh so this
was just like come back oh i found out
the next day that when i passed out
drunk i woke up and there were like
texts from her ex that was visiting the
college that weekend so i was like all
right gang two can play at that game
stop see this is like you're you are
into talking so sick
no no but i understand i understand i
understand what you're saying with like
the tug and pull and like having the
little arguments because sometimes
it brings you closer together in a weird
way exactly so what would be an example
of something that you guys would bicker
about that'd be kind of stupid um
i don't know just like
i
i don't want to see somebody getting the
attention that i i deserve to be getting
just like you don't want to see me
giving another girl attention though
it's like a little game playing right
but at the end of the day i want i'd
rather have a negative situation and
grow from it than just be [ __ ]
perfect because nobody's perfect right
right that's where i start to think that
things are being made that's like super
independent oh 100 percent like they
have their own [ __ ] my best
relationships have been own job when
they go out they almost have resting
[ __ ] face and just like do them like
they don't even want to talk to the
randoms right they barely even want to
talk to me but they're there so true
that's honestly my ideal scenario i need
that little extra push to try and get
somebody to talk to me or open up i mean
i always say my ideal type of guy would
be someone who has a nine to five i
don't see them all day yeah i mean
they'll get dinner and it's good for
dinner and go back honestly why do you
want to talk to them face time every
single day because when sophia and i
were on dating apps a lot of these guys
would pose their job
tech i'm like okay you have an idea for
an app doesn't mean you have a job right
but that's what means you're home 24 00.
exactly exactly are you on any dating
apps i've gotten banned from a lot what
do you mean bam are you screenshotting
no no no no so specifically like girls
report you i get reported on tinder like
in bumble all the time for being a fake
profile oh okay so i got kicked off that
makes sense hinge i got kicked off okay
so
so on hinge you know how it has like
four or five pictures down the line and
they have like questions right so i
always
say i date girls at like girls
that's just like a thing for me okay got
it so i would just only message the
girls i had a photo with one of their
friends
and i just i would just be like so
shocked stop i would just be like so how
close to friends are you guys and stuff
like that and all these girls reported
you for dinner yeah and then why i mean
how would they know that you were doing
that intentionally well i don't know but
hinge sent me an email one day and they
were like we were only like sending out
recorder letting people have accounts
that are looking for relationships i was
like i'm looking for a relationship i
just want them to like girls yeah yeah
yeah just wait yeah i feel like that's
yeah that's that's kind of unfair
it's like sexist a little bit or
something like that
yeah my type is girls that like girls so
like i don't really what about raya oh
i'm mariah that's your fault that wasn't
fine but i'm i i stay calm on raya just
because
i don't need to be canceled by the
actual community yeah i'll get canceled
by the random people for stupid [ __ ] you
know what i don't understand about raya
was when people make this dating profile
and they put just here for friends
yeah what is the what why can't you make
friends like yeah you're using a dating
app to make friends that doesn't make
sense because that's just that's like
going on facebook and messaging somebody
and like having a conversation with you
and being like yo let's go vibe like
come over and like play video games yeah
so so you're looking i would love to
break down what stands out to you when
you're seeing a girl's dating profile
because i remember when i had raya i
would
put like my job and things that were
funny and i was always thinking is it
better to do the funny or the serious
approach
i personally
so like i said i do like a girl that's
funny yeah but i feel like there's a
over
over examination to the fact that like
if you're trying to be funny
i'll see that it's not funny right
i think that's i think i was doing that
i'm not gonna lie i like i like witty
but let's say that i like somebody that
when i have a conversation we can have
banter together and like bounce off of
each other if you're just doing stand up
to me and
any part of it i don't find funny it's
just gonna be cringy i also like someone
that's like naturally funny in the sense
that they did things in the past that
were funny they're like they weren't
self-deprecating like i really were
saying that she would make fun of the
fact that a beast on her throat and
she'll write down her profile a beast
wait wait wait let's we have so much in
common oh my god what happened to you i
was trying to eat a sandwich and it just
went in and
out no way see i was just talking but my
i guess my mouth was really large while
i was talking i haven't been
acknowledging how open your mouth is
when you talk but now it's all about
yeah
oh man i screwed myself but i was just
talking and then it flew and stung my
euphula
and uh i had to pull it out with
tweezers because everyone was grossed
out my family no one would help me and i
was drinking tequila no way i said that
tequila would sterilize it so i only had
to kill sure yeah absolutely that's good
the little look
she's like the beast still hurts my
throat all right just take another shot
by the way i got so many likes on hinge
for that i know and i wrote bionicles do
you remember bionicles the little
that's the thing is when we were writing
that those were the responses that we
got the most from guys was like oh my
god that you're just naturally nerdy or
you're funny right right i think that's
definitely the kicking point yeah
because it's the girls that try too hard
one way or another that's just too much
for me i'd rather no bio right than
somebody trying really hard cause 100
it's serious you actually get to know
them you're not they're not giving their
information to just anybody yeah that's
like something i go for are you
strategic when you when you build your
profile with the types of photos no
you're not no no because girls are very
strategic oh yeah yeah
i haven't changed my photos in a year
see that you know we'll try to do a
sweet one maybe a nice selfie one of a
dog or a burrito and then like we'll try
to do a bikini one but not one that's
like so sexy but just enough it's very
strategic it is strategically look the
guys are like we don't even notice
oh we do this podcast every single week
we go from dating to relationship advice
to mental health to business sometimes
and everything in between but we are
excited to bring on a totally new
segment that will show and hopefully
teach you guys something about saving we
are calling this new segment unfiltered
finance brought to you by moneyline so
you're probably asking
what is moneyline well it is a financial
app full of innovative products that are
designed to help you own your money life
you can download it today in the app
store it combines motivation knowledge
products and offers into a personalized
app experience that helps you own your
money life every single day wow because
honestly there's something that i've
actually been struggling with lately and
i feel like prices are going up all the
time every single day so i've been
trying to figure out ways that i can
save money sophia i've noticed the same
thing i mean my shopping addiction has
taken a serious hit i don't admit it but
i think i'm going through the same
problem so let's just talk about it okay
how do we save better well i know there
are a lot of apps out there that can
help you such as moneyline but i also
think taking a hard look at what we're
spending money on
can help us target the problem areas
i know as you guys know and sistine
definitely knows i'm a foodie so for me
i go out to eat a lot it's one of my
favorite things to do but it eats up a
lot of my money no pun intended
that was a terrible joke thanks you're
welcome
i feel like a great solution to that
would be inviting friends over for a
potluck that's a good way to save that
way you can still enjoy the company but
you will also save money by cooking the
food yourselves that's a great idea
you're welcome
okay
your turn
i love shopping so how are you gonna
help me oh gosh
okay well
if you're okay with it why don't you go
through all your clothes in your closet
and sell some of it then use that money
to go get some new stuff see although i
do have attachment issues to all of my
clothes i don't wear all of them so it's
not a terrible idea to start selling
them and you know what's even better
there's some things i want in your
closet so maybe i will take them off
their hands and buy it from you that's
unacceptable you are not invited to my
garage sale
you see a girl that's out what do you do
to go up to her do you ever like
approach eye contact nope you just stare
at them i don't mean i'm not sitting
across a club eyeballing them
the stare into the camera no it's nice
please do it do you like look them up
and down i mean yeah 100 like i'll just
i'll look from across the club and i'll
just like i'll look take glances i guess
and see if they look my direction which
usually they are not over me but just my
people calls chaos so like usually we
have a lot of intentions at our table
and then i just like eyeball them and
then i don't break the eye contact oh my
god like i let them look away i'm not
looking away but you don't go up to them
no you wait for them to go up to you i
just like i just say come here
come here
do you do that on the dj booth yeah do
you get so many girls doing dj like is
that a i don't recall um well what does
that mean wait what is that i mean i'm
not trying to i'm not here to like
overhype myself no no but that's what
um yes i definitely it works for what it
is why wouldn't it work but i don't i
don't really have a like i definitely
get anxious when i'm djing really
only because like
it's life like anything can happen in
the situation i'm never done anything
live right i've always been like dude
photo shoot comes out six months later
or whatever right right right so
i tend to just ignore people until after
my set
but yeah i mean you get a lot of
attention from it right have you ever
royally messed up djing that was just
not not myself but a whole dj board has
just shut off
like in the middle of everything
are you in trouble for that oh i don't
care i i just literally get on there i'm
like we're going to blame the club for
this one whether it's mine or not yeah
like i just i shoot the blame on another
i just start shuffling and distract
everyone oh i'm like you guys ever heard
slim shady and then just start like
rapping like i dyed my hair blonde i
just caused chaos did you just die
two nights ago last night why yourself
yeah i just get bored oh my god did you
get another tattoo too
you said you got the tattoo recently on
your oh yeah i got my head that's the
new one behind you yeah i just got that
hurt oh yeah i don't know if you can see
it yet
does that hurt really bad which was the
pain most painful my palms ah
i've actually heard that the hands are
the worst together because you have so
many nerves in there that like my arm
kept pulling away so they had to take a
belt and tie me down to the table why
would you want to do that to yourself
well that one was drunk and i have like
ocd so i had to get the other one i have
the balance fair i got that have you
ever regretted any of yours
um i mean i got a couple i got my ex's
name the stripper yeah were you in love
with her yeah well wait wait did you
cover she lied
oh she lied she would continue to lie
yeah i covered it myself i bought a
tattoo gun and just did it myself oh my
god god that's like but we're like so
living the life i had to do it i had to
get my name or her name on me because i
had i needed my name on her if you were
gonna keep dancing oh you put she put
your name on her yeah wait a minute wait
yeah wait a minute
where did you put it mine or hers hers
where was hers her name was right here
like okay that's yeah where was your
name on her
all right all right so you you literally
no
name in red right here so you branded
her because you're like everyone's gonna
stare at your ass being shook
they're gonna look at my name
no she was like i'll do it if you do it
and i'm like yeah
difference is i've got like
60 types wait why did she lie
because that's what girls do okay that's
not true
then you think i like look naturally
beautiful when i wake up in the morning
girls do the craziest stuff i believe
you thank you by the way i'm going to
give you some factors smiling i think
that when we go to the bathroom first
thing in the morning that we're just
like maybe going to the restaurant oh no
i know you're like brushing your teeth
you're contemplating like brushing or
eyebrows concealer curling our lashes a
little bit of blush come back to bed i
know because you guys turn on the sink
so it seems like you're pooping or
something and you don't want to make the
noise when really you're just in there
getting all your [ __ ] done
i'm
did she cheat on you
she would just
it was a lot of like the work thing like
what she was doing and work again my big
thing is truth i can deal with whatever
if you tell me the truth yeah if you lie
to me then then it's [ __ ] we're done
so i would just be like tell me if like
you're doing a dance or you're doing
this or doing that and i would just like
find receipts or whatever from like she
said she didn't do [ __ ]
and so and then it just became a thing
like at home where she had clients text
her and like there was just no
separation to it no you can't do that
which i needed the separation right i
needed that
break from it and every time i wanted
that it seemed as if i was the problem
in it and it just ended up becoming you
ever get um
bothered or does it ever really affect
you when you do get broken up with or if
you break up with someone because i know
with every breakup it you know it hurts
a little bit more and more losing it on
that show i had broken up less than a
month before it filmed no so like with
the month girl yeah with the really
toxic one that had her face id on my
phone that was like we broke up i want
to say like
right after halloween and then i went in
december oh wow that was a quick
turnaround yeah so what were you
thinking you're sitting in the
quarantine for two weeks and you have no
phone well so right before i went in she
started dating another person that's
when i got blocked so that's why i had
no phone oh my god no weed crazy
no people i was like losing my mind
mentally before i even went on the show
right and then you go on the show and it
was it was a therapy experience like i'm
doing workshops yeah did you actually
learn anything from those workshops i
need therapy
my mom calls me like every week with
like a new online therapist she's like
you should go to that what kind of
therapy would you go to i just need
someone to talk to
i just like i just keep it all in my
head because i i feel like i can handle
the world yeah and then eventually like
every once in a while i'll just pop up
and i'll just have like a moment where
like i'll lose it or i'll act the type
of way that i usually wouldn't or
something yeah yeah i don't actually
have like any situations that go on
daily i don't think but no like it was
really nice going on the show and like
and like learning things that's why i
went on like a maniac and i came out of
it very calm that wasn't right it wasn't
fake or anything like that like i
actually was relaxed
you had the biggest jump
when i saw it thank you yeah i i
personally think
the relationship i built the most was
with myself right because beforehand i
would literally call some girl and be
like just come over and cuddle and
that's the only way i could sleep i
couldn't sleep alone really like i hated
it i couldn't fall asleep i'd be up till
six in the morning like sitting in bed
and now like since coming back from it
and dealing with a month of no phone no
people know this or that i'm so much
better with just being by myself and
like relaxed and not eating anything
right that's actually yeah so but you're
so you pegged me as a relationship guy
that you're more comfortable being in
one serial monogamist
that's how i am too i love sharing my
day with exactly or doing things like
that with someone well being three years
single so far yeah i've like missed yeah
it's been so long but like i miss
actually having someone to talk to every
day i'm at a year and a half that's the
longest i've ever gone
but i do have to say dating for a girl
in l.a is much harder than dating her
guy there are so many pretty women there
aren't true the girls in l.a you can
just pick them out of a lineup they're
all pretty
again but they're all pretty doesn't
matter exactly that's true like think of
it this way okay your choices in your
head not as many attractive dudes or
whatever you have less options it's also
less
options to [ __ ] up and have to deal with
yeah i've got so many pretty options
that i have to make it through every one
of them to find one that's actually
normal or one that actually i can vibe
with it's a lot more difficult in my
opinion because i've got
too many people to possibly try and make
something work with where they all end
up [ __ ] it's we always say that the only
way that we find someone that you
actually are going to work out with is
if you're instantly comfortable with
that 100 like they're your best friend
within the week i need to be able to go
from like you come over and have a movie
night or something to literally spend a
week in a row and not be tired of each
other like i need to be obsessed with
you if i'm not obsessed with you then as
toxic as that may sound i just you know
you're you're way more emotional than i
thought oh yeah i'm a basket case i love
it that's the case i love when people
wear their heart on their sleeves yeah
that's so important again you don't
think it when you see my profile or
stuff like that but that's why i put on
this all the tattoos
i don't want you to think you know me i
want to be able to surprise you are you
the guy that says first and foremost the
girl like exactly what you want for sure
oh so you're very direct when you tell a
girl if you like like them right i like
you i wanted this correct yeah oh now
i've been told that i i ghost
yeah i've been told
sources say but yeah it's word on the
grapevine is but i don't intentionally
it's more of a
i get really about someone and then they
annoy me or they do something that
sketches me out or something like that
and i just decide to walk away mm-hmm
what was the problem
instead of saying what the problem oh
yeah yeah but like i mean i'll say the
problem once or twice but as soon as
it's repetitive and you keep asking me
questions about it or this and that i'll
just leave rather than try and handle it
because
uh if i can't if you don't get what i'm
putting down and you keep acting like a
type of way do you think that you're
going for the same type of girl every
time now do you think that you're
looking in the wrong place
so um perhaps maybe a library or a
museum
coffee shop i mean
no crazy girls can like coffee too yeah
that's true i'm bucks
i guess they're everywhere
i just you know i tried not to look for
them at all anymore i think that's the
best way to go about it i think that's
it'll fall into my lap when it's meant
to happen yeah i don't wake up during
the day like i said i'm i'm asleep till
noon i feel like you need a girl that's
polar opposite from 100 like does not
get tattoos randomly it does in the gym
i need someone to tie me down
she's making you celery juice for when
you wake up that's what i need but then
you can bring her up by saying like
let's do crazy things like let's go out
ladies and then and then i don't have
the anxiety either because i do have
anxiety so like i'm not thinking what
you're doing at night or this is that
she needs to be deep like almost like an
in-house therapist for you i need a girl
that's asleep by 10 pm yeah and willing
to hear all my issues because if you
don't hear it someone else will and we
don't need that yeah she doesn't strip
for something that's going to be so easy
to find mind stripping by the way i i
don't by the way we don't even hey we
don't either
we love miami we love we did love miami
11 was yeah
no it's funny because when we go to
miami um they always say that our dad
used to go out a ton in miami so all
these bounces would know when he was
younger young out of my nose yeah what
do you say they called him the king of
miami really will smith wrote in our
blood is that about him yep
yes
and uh he still we had we were going out
this is when we knew it was alarming we
would go out uh yeah and old old
promoters would come up to us and be
like your dad had a table everything
oh my god this is nuts i'm like and
we're here it's like
full circle yeah it was bad we are gonna
do some rapid fire questions oh for [ __ ]
don't worry about it they're super easy
they're like nine questions so i'll
start ready
one celebrity crush
sydney sweeney ah
that's a great answer are you watching
her this season of course she's how do
you feel about her mental breakdown
she's pretty toxic
the fact that she's like very about
you know in the show at least she's
always like apologizing and trying to
make sure somebody else is okay and make
sure that like they're loved and they
feel type away yeah that's very much how
i feel like i am in a relationship and
like i'm constantly trying to make sure
the other person is okay and and so i i
respect that a lot plus she's gorgeous
also she's building her own ford bronco
i i didn't know about that on tech talk
look at sid's garage she built her own
bronco from scratch
she i mean she's the jack of all trades
really said if you want to get married
hit me up that's what i'm saying uh okay
she was watching this i lose my mind
sophia this question if you had to play
a song
every time forever when you had sex
which song would it be every time you
get sex a song came on what would it
have to be
pina colad
stop no it wouldn't not be peanut
actually that's not a bad one it's kind
of slow it's slow it plays in the
background and it plays in my head like
elevator music anyway i think i would
never have a pina colada ever again i
don't like peanut butter first off i
love pina coladas it's not for me
yeah i like just straight up whiskey or
tequila but honestly that song can
either be background music or you can
laugh with it and be a vibe yeah or it
can be really romantic it just plays on
like everything thank god that's great
actually that's funny so if you would
play opera or some [ __ ] okay false
like i've been to an opera one time i
love you okay
you really yeah she's like i love the
phantom of the offer
i literally like spotify it's like
awkward classics okay you know
just because i'm worldly doesn't mean
okay who was your first kiss
uh kindergarten some girl named whitney
whitney yeah i was in my backyard by the
swings how was it
i don't remember my mom said it was
great oh that's so cute oh you need a
chaperone for that all right how much
money would it take for you to streak
across a field during an nfl game am i
going to get arrested um let you know
let's just say you know you pop over to
the front
free i don't give a [ __ ] are you not
even a dollar you just i mean if you
want to give me a dollar buy me a drink
i'll do it but like he's like if you
just said he's like just a whiskey you
look at me and you say you won't i'll
i'll do it
so when people dare you you just go for
it oh yeah i'm not i don't get
embarrassed that's why i like with all
like crying stuff and everything like
everybody's giving me [ __ ] i'm like i
really don't care i don't excuse me [ __ ]
about crying oh you should see my my
mentions
they're all over that but like i just is
it mostly men that are giving you [ __ ]
or no there's some girls too but like i
really i don't if the way i look at it
i'd rather be infamous and famous if
you're talking about me in any light
you're still talking about me retweeting
oh that's true what was that quote that
people say it's better we talked about
the knot
yeah someone said that and i was like
well like if you're infamous for doing
stupid [ __ ] or looking bad then no one
expects you to look good anyway
you can do whatever you want
start looking ugly
we look really good best advice you
received
best advice i've received yeah be
yourself that's really it like have you
been told it since your kids and stuff
and everyone thinks it's corny or like
it's just your parents talking to you or
whatever but really if i wasn't just
doing me i'd be miserable right the only
reason i'm okay with everything that
goes on in the world is because i know
it's me and i'm not faking for anybody
amen i love that okay
i'm like why am i gonna get all the
crazy questions
because i kept doing it i could all
right if you could have an endless
supply of anything
what would it be excluding money
i think that would be it but like not
like i want i want to be friends like i
want to own a strip club i want to i
want to be like oh my god you're going
to be like
i want to call it the litter box okay
i was going to say what's the next name
oh my god your ball
box because it's like pussycats [ __ ]
okay you need to write a song
that's so dirty the little little oh
it's down and grimy
i don't want a gentleman i'm sorry i'm
sunset like this is like the body shop
i'm your first investor i love body shop
by the way i have so many friends that
work at body shop it's amazing i love
body shops
i took a girl home from body shop and
the next day i woke up to airpod pros
and gucci sweatpants she gave it to you
she instacarted them to me
wait so you were the baby you were the
uh the sugar
baby
i've had sugar moments i love being sure
honestly i i i was opposite last time i
know well i kind of well no i went in i
threw 100 i got 250 and gear back it was
like it was investment the biggest turn
off that you've ever experienced
if you if we're on a date and you like
give a guy another tensioner make eye
contact with him like i was on a date
with this girl we were walking down the
street and this guy walked by and full
like head break like neck breaking like
turn and look at him i literally was
like all right i'm out oh she was you
know she did that and i was like i'm out
did you actually leave the date yeah i
got in the car left what i said
i was going on a double date with her i
said maybe if he'd like me more if a guy
sent me a drink like she asked the
wizard she no see that that's a vibe i'm
for that no
i said this to do that so then it looked
like like a guy thought i was cute right
because at the end it was bad but like
if none of my homies think want my girl
or think she's attractive or whatever
i'm like all right that's whatever
like i need that confirmation that other
people want them to said this for and
it's like because i told the guy that he
said i would have been totally turned
off because why would it go it would
look like your eyes no but it's not it's
not your fault that somebody's thinking
about you
it's one thing if you take that drink
over and you say thank you and all that
[ __ ] that right well like if you're just
getting it it's confirmation to me that
other people want you let me step it up
a bit okay so why don't we do this next
time that you go on a date okay you give
us a call and you're gonna come we'll
sit at the bar we'll buy you a drink so
that it makes and if it's not going well
we can just all hang out yes perfect
if you could fight any celebrity in a
boxing match who would it be
in a boxing match you know what justin
bieber oh actually
that's why because i've been called
justin bieber since i was like 10 years
old
no not at all it's a compliment he's the
richest little white kid in the world
like he's killing it but i'd love to
take him on i'd love to just like that i
am superior oh you think you'd win oh
yeah
or how tall are you yeah
okay what the [ __ ] is that supposed to
mean
she's a very are you kidding me i don't
know like
does he work out like justin i don't ask
him i don't know yeah
i'm six one i don't know and yes i
[ __ ] i don't know i can't you ask
foreigner oh really i use i've i've
wrestled i i train like i like to fight
i used to be the kid that would like
look for a i was betting money on justin
i'll put money on you oh no i'm crazy
i'll i'll start throwing hands so yeah
i'm gonna type where if someone fights
at the club i'm like sophia let's get a
better view and she's like oh for sure
i'm like i want to see no yeah i i went
to a party not too long ago people were
fighting i like climbed up the window
what's your question now i'm nervous
well no so good ask questions i actually
have two questions okay go one being out
here like i don't i don't know if you
guys grew up in la or something like
that but do you feel like your life
would have been different had your dad
not been who he was like do you feel
like absolutely do you admire that you
are where you are now because of it or
totally do you wish that you were like
it's interesting because we grew up
really sheltered from everything okay
and then really yeah they didn't want
yeah they didn't want to do anything
entertainment we like went to catholic
school did our homework never got a
detention we're really straight and
narrow
and then uh it sort of got to an age
where like
well no no
then we lost our minds no and then it
got to the point where a lot of people
would only
recognize us or want to be friends with
us or want to date us
because of that and it bothered me for a
little bit but then i sort of had to
remind myself that
i'm so incredibly proud of the career
that he's had so if i'm ever embarrassed
by it that's just a stupid insecurity on
my part like
i should lift it i definitely think i
would probably be in a different career
like okay totally opposite career but
this falls into your lap a little bit
yeah well in the sense that we're raised
around cameras and we have a very very
loud family dynamic and so entertaining
yeah and entertainment being open and
honest on camera talking to each other
it's always been very natural to us but
i feel like if we weren't raised around
that are you kind of i think you'd hear
something yeah here's the thing like
my my friend's dad and his mom are both
real estate agents so he does real
estate because that's what he knows when
you grow up in a house that all you know
is hollywood entertainment it just makes
sense like i don't i couldn't do
something else because you literally
only know that and i i've always seen
myself even as a kid i was like i'm
going to be a [ __ ] star well you guys
are killing it i think i would have been
a doctor
what
i should i feel like a research analyst
all right i'm really good at research
okay i'm really really good okay well
well let's let's wrap the show oh i got
one more question okay another question
what color do we make this
oh cause i'm going through it right now
is this the base color of the next color
you want to go into would you do a crazy
color oh yeah i'm doing i'm i'm up front
i'm gonna go green i was looking at red
i don't think you should do green i
wanted to do like a baby blue but my
homie just did baby blue i don't want to
copy them i don't know you should do
pink lilac like purple good lavender
yeah like a lavender lavender like a
light purple i actually think that would
look so good with your eyes or a teal
a teal that's like a green so my boy
just did light blues like ice blue no no
i would do so i'm trying to stay away
from what other people do because you
know on me i'm fine
all right so i'm gonna do lavender yeah
i'll send you guys a photo and if you
hate it i'm going right my friend has
this guy that actually hair that's
exactly like yours he does the sickest
design designs oh my god they're insane
i want to start painting my head and
just have like some little artist [ __ ]
oh my god i can't wait to see what
rainbow i hate like you know what a girl
told me one time that she said date a
hairdresser because they're always
changing their hair and it's like you're
with someone new everybody oh look at
that
actually that's kind of fun to date you
then because you probably just changed
your personality and look all the time
so it's not like you're dating the same
person yeah you guys ever want to do
this again i'll just bring some paint so
we can just paint my hair and have i
would love to i cut my owner she never
lets me touch people's hair cut your own
hair oh yeah all right i'll bring the
trimmers you can do the whole thing yeah
oh i love it okay well that's what we're
doing next time all right i love that
for us
all right tell everyone where they can
find your social media where they can
see your dj set um yeah so
steven did her on everything uh yaddy
daddy on everything is my dj name daddy
daddy daddy daddy
where did that come from and on the east
coast if you're tatted you say yatted
yeah so daddy yeti daddy i guarantee
you're asking for it buddy yeah i'm here
i'm here to piss people off so come
listen to my [ __ ] uh go watch me be an
idiot on social media or enough perfect
well thank you guys so much for joining
us
[Music]
[Music]
you